a familiar wizard an important helmet
and yet another superhero team there's
more going on in Black Adam than you
might expect and it's all steeped in DC
Comics lore you might not know
the Justice Society of America has
appeared or been alluded to in many
different animated series and
live-action shows CW Series Star Girl
even features two different incarnations
of the team but Black Adam sees a JSA
debut in the DC EU which is an entirely
different tier of recognition this group
is presented as a peacekeeping
organization and is implied to have many
more members than the four who figure in
this film's Mission well that mission
easily could have been a job for Amanda
Waller's Infamous task force x or an
opportunity to use the better known
Justice League bringing the JSA to the
big screen as a power all its own one
that's easy to overlook if you haven't
got the necessary Comics knowledge for
most of his fictional history Black Adam
has been a villain both things change in
the pages of the 1999 JSA comic series
here Adam undergoes an evolution and a
change of heart that realigns him as an
edgy anti-hero much of that progression
comes from his proximity to the JSA
composed here of Elder Heroes who have
been fighting the good fights since the
1940s they offer Adam a sense of kinship
and he is similarly displaced in time
only more so thus putting the JSA in
Black Adam's first feature film rather
than another super team strikes a
meaningful note for fans of the comics
Black Adam is a film that moves a bit
too quickly to muster much time for
delving into its supporting players
backstories but there are a handful of
nods to Comics law that eagle-eyed fans
should recognize immediately one
especially Vivid example is a scene
where Atom Smasher tells Cyclone how
impressed he is now that he's seen her
superpowers in action he explains that
his powers are hereditary and express
his curiosity about the nanobot driven
aspects of our own wind-based abilities
she tells him she was kidnapped by an
evil scientist as a child who performed
experiments on her this Dreadful
experience left her with the ability to
control the wind Cyclone doesn't refer
to the Sinister perpetrator by name but
Die Hard fans will know exactly who she
means in the pages of DC Comics Cyclone
AKA Maxine Hunker gets her powers from
being experimented on by Professor T.O
Morrow the same mad scientist who
created the Red Tornado Mario has been a
villain in the DC Universe for years
frequently crossing paths with JSA and
the Justice League is also appeared in
multiple small screen DC adaptations
including Supergirl and Young Justice
but he'd never appeared in a live-action
movie before Black Adam hit theaters
perhaps we'll see more of this malicious
madman in Future movie outings and
hopefully Cyclone as well
Black Adam makes room for a number of
delightful JSA related cameos but one
related to atom smash's heroic Legacy is
particularly enjoyable on the ride over
to the mission debrief Atom Smasher is
on a video call with Al Pratt the
original atom played wonderfully by
Henry Winkler Uncle Al tells him to be
careful with the suit as it's a very
special family heirloom in the comics
Albert prata's Godfather to Atom Smasher
whose real name is Al rostin the film
seems to have simplified their
Connection by making him an elderly
relative instead sidestepping the need
to address the complexity of his comic
book Origins and how many decades
they'll separate the modern day and the
1940s the 1999 JSA comic series a huge
influence on Black Adam in many ways is
big on introducing second and third
generation Heroes while keeping the
veterans around to show the rookies a
thing or two seeing galprat reference on
the Silver Screen is a wonderful way to
continue that Legacy and indicate the
character's Deep Roots any future
cinematic appearances from the Justice
Society will do well to follow in this
cameo's footsteps if only to bring in
such excellent character actors even if
we don't get Alan Scott's Green Lantern
or Jay Garrick's flash we definitely
need more Henry Winkler in the DC EU
in Black Adam Hawkman initially appears
to be the Justice society's answer to
Batman he's Rich lives in a big mansion
has a Gruff leader Vibes covered and
crucially lacks superpowers it's not
until we see the science fictional ship
he and the team travel in that we get a
vivid glimpse of what makes him
extraordinary the entire ship as he
tells Cyclone is made of enth metal this
highly Advanced and mega powerful
substance also makes up his armor wings
and mace the latter object is a huge and
devastating creation that transforms
into other weapons throughout the film
most notably it acts in the comics nth
metal originates on thanagar the planets
some other iterations of Hawkman come
from the film's Hawkman whose secret
identity is Carter Hall doesn't appear
to be one of the Hawkman who is actually
from outer space but by openly
referencing the storied metal Black Adam
hints at the cosmic side of the dceu
which has yet to be fully explored
mentioning nth metal also brings a
Darkly magical side of the DC Universe
to the before the Fey board substance
plays a major role in the 2017 Dark
Knights metal comic events which
introduces the Arcane dark Multiverse it
remains to be seen how the dceu might
incorporate enth Metal's fascinating
history but this Easter egg definitely
wets fans appetites for more
there's a moment that happens early in
Black Adam where Kent Nelson AKA Dr Fate
leaves his helmets out on the Justice
Society ship Atom Smasher tries to touch
it and Hawkman tells him not to he
explains that it's otherworldly and only
works for the wearer it has chosen to be
its host tragically Dr Fate later
sacrifices himself to buy the team some
time against the buck which allows Black
Adam to break free from its underwater
prison Hawkman a close friend and Ally
of Fates is able to temporarily use the
helmet at a key point in the battle
suggesting the helmet trusts him the
same way it did Nelson but when that
moment comes to an end the helmet
disappears entirely in the comics the
helmets of Fate is sometimes known as
the helmets of Naboo as have many hosts
over the years when Nelson dies and his
shuffles away Comics fans know it's
probably off to find its successor Dr
Fate is source of like DC's equivalent
to Marvel sorcerer Supreme it's a hugely
powerful magical title that demands
nearly everything from those who bear it
Kent Nelson is probably be the most
noteworthy duck to fate but he's
definitely not the only one a dceu is
probably unlikely to take things back to
the 90s and bring angst ridden Jared
Stevens to the big screen but they might
introduce audiences to Caleb nassor a
young Egyptian American man from New
York City who is the comics current Dr
Fate
Black Adam goes out of its way to
disassociate itself from the 2019 Shazam
film this is likely due to the two
outings diametrically opposed tones
Shazam is light and Airy in a way Black
Adam just can't afford to be but that
doesn't stop the connections between
these two movies from bubbling forth in
the film's many flashbacks to Adam's
Origins meted out over the course of the
movie in exponentially more revealing
bus actor jimin hansu appears as a
wizard Shazam this powerful magic user
plays an important part in Shazam DC
enigmatic figure who gives Billy Batson
his superpowers you want me to do magic
with this
all my Powers will become yours
he doesn't get any dialogue or more than
a passing glance in Black Adam but
here's a mistakeable Visage tethers the
film to the larger dceu and Adam himself
to the universe's most ancient entities
Adam's flashback sequence also explored
the central tragedy of his cinematic
origin he himself was not shazam's
chosen Champion his son was knowing he
could not kill the boy the vicious King
uncut slew his family instead Adam's son
gave his father the power of Shazam in
an effort to save his life it worked
which meant Adam was forced to watch the
King's Men brutally murder his suddenly
mortal son this is a tragic and moving
subversion of black Adam's modern Comics
origin there he killed the boy to seize
his powers for himself
but much of Black Adam Adriana and her
son Amman represent the human elements
within a Fantastical world of gods
Wizards and superheroes their struggle
in yearning for Khan dark to be free
grounds all the action and Intrigue in
something decidedly Earthbound but in
the comics these two characters are far
from ordinary bystanders writer and DC
Universe architect Jeff Johns has
contributed more to the Black Adam
Mythos in the last 20 years than any
other comic scribe one of the biggest RC
pens for the character takes place in
2006's 52 Series in this comic a Black
Adam creates his own dark version of the
Marvel family turning Adriana and Amman
into Isis and Osiris Isis as some may
recognize is also a call back to the
secret of Isis a 1975 television series
that formed the latter half of the
Shazam Isis hour
oh Zephyr winds which flow on high lift
me now so I can fly
the 1974 Shazam series which formed the
other half was actually the first
live-action adaption of the Captain
Marvel Mythos though Isis later appeared
in Smallville and legends of Tomorrow
Black Adam marks her first appearance in
the DC EU albeit in a deep powered state
Black Adam is a film with Loosely
anti-colonial themes it presents the
fictional nation of Khan dark as a
Middle Eastern country that has been
oppressed and exploited by foreign
powers for much of its existence in the
present-day Khan dark is run by an
organization called enter gang who seems
to be a tech obsessed band of
mercenaries in search of the crown of
sabark though they're certainly
important the film shifts gears away
from them to primarily focus on Ishmael
and his connection to the Ancient King
on cart uniquely sharp-eyed fans might
recognizing to gang from Superman the
animated series before they recall the
group's Comics history in that cartoon
they're frequently featured as
antagonists to the Man of Steel this
animated adaptation keeps them largely
in line with the comics but they're a
hugely powerful criminal organization
when something like a corporation they
also boast seriously Advanced Tech and
sci-fi Weaponry originating from
apocalypse though they're a constant
thorn in the Big Blue Boy Scout side
intergang is often presented as
something of an appetizer to an
inevitable Dark Side appearance I take
it the battle is not going well as the
dark side teasing ending of Zack
Snyder's justice league isn't treated as
DC EU Cannon it's unlikely that
intergang is being used in Black Adam as
a similar indication of upcoming fourth
world adventures they're pretty much one
of the male Boogeyman who become fodder
for Adam's vengeful Carnage but who
knows maybe we'll see more of them in
the future complete with apocalyptic and
weaponry
like the 2019 Shazam film Black Adam
acknowledges superheroes and World
celebrity and pop culture presence in
the former movie Billy Batson and
Freddie Freeman are aware of Superman
and his Justice League compatriots
Freddy even owns a well-loved selection
of hero themed t-shirts in Black Adam
Amman acts as a resident Fanboy when we
first meet him at an intergang
checkpoint we see a stack of comics fall
out of his backpack then we see his
bedroom which is absolutely plastered
with superhero posters Black Adam wakes
up within this room and inadvertently
destroys a poster bearing Superman's
image with his lightning powers
foreshadowing a cataclysmic showdown
between two Titans of the DC universe
beyond the Man of Steel a man is also
tagged up posters of Aquaman and the
Flash the kid further cements his status
as a movie's resident geek by giving
Black Adam advice about how to be a hero
according to Amman Adam should go about
developing a catchphrase a more modern
nickname and a cape this portrayal is a
loving nod to Incan paper superhero fans
everywhere famed to their comprehensive
knowledge of hero tropes and towering
stacks of comic books many audience
members see their own young selves in a
man and perhaps recall their own post to
filled bedrooms
the DC Universe is home to a number of
high security institutions meant to keep
the bad guys safely contained Gotham
City has the infamous Arkham Asylum and
Blackgate Penitentiary Metropolis has
Strikers Island Central cities got iron
Heights bright outside of Saint Rock
Hawkman stomping grounds lies Bell Reeve
the prison Amanda Waller Farms future
task force ex-operatives from Black Adam
reveals another one of warless
high-priced cages when she tests the
Justice Society with capturing and
detaining Adam augment tells her that if
she's got a cell that can hold him
they'll put him there this cell ends up
being an unnamed facility hidden in an
underwater base when Adam eventually
makes his way there in his deep powered
State we see that other high-powered
individuals are locked up in close
proximity suggesting this is where
Wallace sashes The Heavy Hitters and
suitable for use as cannon fodder on
suicide missions though when named this
place feels a lot like the aquarium an
underwater prison that occasionally
shows up in Aquaman Centric Comics it's
hard to imagine the atlanteans of the
dceu working with Waller on this unless
a dramatic change has occurred off
screen but who knows Amanda Waller is
renowned for her ability to make the
impossible into cold hard reality
when the Justice Society brings Adam to
the deep sea Penitentiary for holding
there's a familiar face lurking in the
crowd this is Amelia Harcourt an Argus
agent from The Suicide Squad last seen
in season 1 of Peacemaker she gets less
than a minute of screen time to interact
with our heroes in Black Adam but within
that brief Cameo she's able to Amberly
display the no-nonsense attitude that
makes her so much fun Amanda Waller is
fantastic as the DC eu's closest thing
to Nick Fury but Fury doesn't work alone
he has agents to support him Amelia
Harcourt plays a similar role and does
so wonderfully a brief presence is also
a particularly fun treat for fans of
Peacemaker and helps this DC Universe
feel a little more coherent across
movies and TV
[Music]